Museum of the Bible in Washington DC
removed five items previously displayed
as fragments of the Dead Sea Scrolls
after an embarrassing discovery they
were found to be fake
experts say testing shows the fragments
were inconsistent with ancient origin
the admission is calling attention to
the role of forensic science in making
sure ancient artifacts are in fact
ancient chip Reid is outside the museum
in Washington chip good morning well
good morning the Dead Sea scroll
fragments are believed to date back to
the time of Jesus they were found in
Israel in the 1940s and 50s and soon
some of the 80,000 fragments started
appearing on the market and some were
sold to museums now this museum admits
that part of its collection may have
been forged fragments that were
purportedly part of the
two-thousand-year-old Dead Sea Scrolls
have been on display at Washington's
Museum of the Bible since it opened last
year but now technical analysis has
shown at least five of the museum's 16
fragments including these two are likely
forgeries museum chief curator Jeffrey
Chloe the questions that have come up
have been sufficient enough that were
not confident in displaying them as
authentic artifacts the fragments in
question were purchased between 2009 and
2014 by the green family the evangelical
owners of the Hobby Lobby chain of craft
stores and the museum's largest donor
the tiny fragments were the museum's
centerpiece collection but there were
concerns about their authenticity even
before the museum opened we certainly
had lots of questions but we decided
that this was an opportunity to help
educate the public about different
research methods the fragments went
through multiple rounds of testing first
in 2016 by a team that concluded the
markings were likely not two thousand
years old
researcher Kip Davis the forgeries that
I'm dealing with are ancient pieces of
leather or parchments that have been
written on in modern times further
technical analysis by a German company
that used x-ray scanning along with ink
and sediment analysis can
that the fragments are apparently
forgeries the Dead Sea Scrolls are
believed to represent the earliest
surviving pieces of the Old Testament
and are worth millions to museums and to
forgers a number of these institutions
all own their own Dead Sea scroll
fragments and have paid an incredible
amount of money some biblical scholars
have warned that fake fragments are
being marketed to American evangelical
Christians as for the rest of this
museums fragment collection they say
they're going to get to get them tested
and they will release the results Yale
all right thank you chip Reid let's pray
for a resolution on this prayer is
always good in all circumstances